my name is Joe Biden I'm a Democratic
candidate for the United States Senate
look me over your legacy help out it's
not both the other by give me a look
though okay
question of the day okay this is a
serious question I'm not joking around
at all I genuinely think and I want I
really think that Vice President Joe
Biden may have early onset dementia I
want to get to the debates a little bit
but give you a little bit more context
here obviously was very interesting last
night from Bloomberg accidentally
admitting Lee bought politicians
everybody's talking about that too this
is not one of the reason I think he has
dementia but it's just funny so let's
leave with a tip to Joe Biden coining
the phrase first-time Home Boehner's I
provide for the opportunity for a
first-time homebuyer homebuyers
okay now that is funny dimension
notwithstanding it's not because of the
lobe or the cerebral cortex it just
boners but just that's a slip of the
tongue
Biden's always been known for gaffes
right but I think there's a little bit
there's a little more by the way than
gaffes and the past Joe Biden like
people may say like Barack Obama said 57
states or George W Bush would say it's a
new cooler President Donald Trump I'm
sure there are some in there I know
Feifei okay that's a tweet really but
that's just probably he just was like I
don't need autocorrect he thinks it is
better he thinks he can beat the system
he's a kind of dad of Google Maps or any
things he can beat the map you can never
beat the maps a lot of hope for AI but
Joe Biden Joe Biden would make up
stories about times that never happened
with people he's never met in places
that don't even exist and it used to be
just a guy with no accountability who
didn't think that anyone was going to
fact-check him at all but I don't see
that anymore I really don't think that
he's in on the joke so a couple things
here's a I think we have seven examples
and there are more but I wanted his a
lot of top seven the seventh example
where I think he might actually have
some dementia is a he starts stop you
can seem stopping and stuttering and
stopping mid-sentence I'd make it clear
to China we are going to continue to
move closer to make sure that we can in
fact prevent China prevent North Korea
from launching missiles to take them
down and if we don't look why am i
stopping you
no stops okay man will laughter Joe and
then he stops yeah look you'd think he'd
continue like why am i stopping and then
well then why am i no one else stops I'm
going to continue which is why myself he
talked about getting arrested in South
Africa and then after some more context
well it makes it even worse this day
thirty years ago Nelson Mandela walked
out of prison and entered into
discussions about apartheid I had the
great honour of meeting him I had the
great honour of being arrested with our
UN Ambassador the streets of sway dope
trying to get the seam I'm not easily
fed check ok I should be clear that
obvious wasn't for the debate most of
these are from the debate then some
others I just wanted to pull from the
vault right next to Walt Disney's
anti-semitic corpse what makes this so
bad the UN Ambassador said that's a lie
he said that's not true at all and this
is an example right there of someone who
doesn't have any self-awareness Joe
Biden I think Joe Biden thought he was
going to waltz through this yeah yeah
it's so like JFK with the jaundice and
all the painkillers and all the affairs
and the venereal diseases he just
thought no one's ever going to know
because no one loves me
he doesn't know that the internet exists
right exactly exactly he does not know
that the internet exists and that this
will exist in perpetuity and he just
doesn't realize that people are going to
be fact-checking him and that's really
been his Achilles heel here is just that
people can say we didn't remind and
that's the end of his campaign and we
have somebody get even more egregious
but we're laughing because these are
funny you know they're funny when you
take them out of context and it's just
the clips but when you add them up and
having dealt with family members who had
Alzheimer's of dementia
I really see some of the signs people
feeling like they kind of forget where
they are getting a little bit flustered
not being able to find their words it's
beyond just fatigue and I don't even
know how he could be that fatigued he's
not really making that many stars right
now he is the most lazy campaign I think
you've ever seen he doesn't I don't even
think he knows how to spell a ground
game let's go to example number five
where he said that he yet he worked with
this is one to with with shout pain
non-joking ain't jumping one of those
names here you
one thing's not proudest of it's getting
past getting moved kicking getting
control the Paris climate Accord
I'm the guy that came back after meeting
with dumb chopping and making the case
that I believe China was going if we put
pressure on we're gonna get back to more
that are in the debates but I just like
that one because the man in question had
been dead for over ten years so this is
again that comes from just not caring
that people are going well honk wailing
he's always been dead for ten years
that's a lie
Joe you're cray either you're crazy or
that's a lie and then he starts talking
about punching a guy in the face and
wrapping his hand in a chain at Amy's
diner and what are you talking about I
don't know I don't know and here's
another one I think this is from the
debate I really this was a Vice
President Biden and like I said it's
because if you don't laugh you'll cry
which I think he did after the debates
this is Vice President Biden against
professional 16-ounce beverage banner in
chief Bloomberg I am a fan of Obamacare
at the beginning mr. vice president I
just checked the record because you've
said one time that I was not in oh nine
I testified and gave a speech before the
sign-on and Isis that time I wrote an
article praising Obamacare was either in
the New York Post of The Daily News so
the facts are I was there let me finish
thank you
no you can't hop in there President Joe
Biden Mandelbaum Mandelbaum Mandelbaum
the CEO that reminded me on specifically
when Bloomberg and Biden would go after
each other it reminded me of this early
internet viral video now watch this when
he swings and it's a downward driveway
listen to the sound generation that is
by what why men and women are different
every guy I've shown that video laughs
his ass off and every woman goes oh
that's that's is he okay no he's
probably not and he he was starting to
buy the land if you're subscribed hit
the notification bell and hit all
notifications because subscriptions
don't mean a whole lot and do consider
running mud club for example this is
taken from an entire hour show that's
not available on YouTube because we're
not monetized
here's another oh this is one that I
loved that a lot of people didn't catch
not so much indicative of dementia you
know just um it's kind of a dick so this
is where we talked about is this what he
promises a black yes a black wouldn't
sorry heap sorry I don't want to offend
people I don't want to take care of
african-american woman on the Supreme
Court but it's what he says after that's
a tell the fact is what we should be
doing we talked about the Supreme Court
I'm looking forward to making sure
there's a black woman on the Supreme
Court to make sure
not a joke a joke right this is a comedy
game router joke not a joke and you know
what that tells me too by the way I said
when someone says okay let me be honest
with you
what were you being before Yeah right
what was happening for the other 45
minutes of this conversation that's not
a joke it's not a joke okay and that's
people give me Jimmy Fleck and
rightfully so I often say by the way or
we've talked about this yeah but that
word whisker is me trying to encourage
you to fact check this show like we've
talked about this in other words go
through the archives we've been
consistent we've mentioned this in the
past I can't be bothered to do overlays
50,000 times and if you don't know how
to use a bibliography that's your fault
not mine I'm like The Young Turks we do
provide sources or if I say by the way
I'm going oh this is something I forgot
it's important him saying it's not a
joke is saying I'm a lying human all the
time outside of this one instant except
for right now except for right now and
let me be clear - I don't want to play
by a double estate
I don't think Vice President Joe Biden
is racist I really don't I think that's
kind of just a little bit tone-deaf like
a somewhat ignorant aunt who might not
be super familiar with black people
confuse him because she thinks they all
look alike you know that kind of thing
doesn't mean that this person is racist
I just think that it is piss your pants
funny and here's another one that's that
I again I don't know if it's just a word
whisker with Vice President Joe Biden
because he doesn't correct himself you
notice that no no the ones I'm actually
corrects and he corrected himself
yesterday he said no wait let me and he
corrected himself and repeated the exact
same thing look up to him for the
consistency even his Corrections we need
to know how many Pennell there wasn't a
correction just it's still Pinocchio's
this one I don't know he never corrected
it so I don't know if he believes it if
he was poorly equipped or again when you
had this accumulative Lee just like
cumulative concussive syndrome maybe he
has some dementia going on where he
talks about gun violence imagine if I
stood here and said we give immunity to
drug companies we give immunity tobacco
companies that is caused carnage on our
streets a hundred and five
deep million people have been killed
since 2007 when Bernie voted to exempt
the gun manufacturers from liability
half the population of the country is
now the one thing said 150 million
people no way then you go okay it's Ord
whisker but it goes more than all wars
in Vietnam and they're like okay Joe
just stop while you're not ahead it's
just a hundred and fifty million people
dead yeah since 2007 in ten years half
the country so Walking Dead doesn't see
those kind of mortality rates I know as
he corrected it since I haven't seen him
correctly I've seen it burn he's like
he's wrong good question no all right
this was the biggest disaster and also
that Donald Trump will be president in
2020 tomorrow we'll be talking about
that Gavin McInnes will be on the show
laying out the case as to why I think
it's like a 90% chance that he wins
could you imagine if President Trump or
let's just go back to george w bush yeah
had something that wrong you know had it
off a check to the in 150 million
because at that point i think the number
is 400,000 all the sources with me again
i'm going by wrote here you guys fact
checked me i think it's four hundred
thousand total gun deaths since 2007 i
could be off plus or minus a few let's
even say a couple hundred thousand but
with 150 million that's not even a
rounding error he's sorry off by a
hundred and fifty million no correction
and I watched the postgame around I
watched Anderson Cooper
I watched him in Don Lemon any other
host you could fit in your back pocket
who else aunt Charlie all sashay on back
to their homes their old repurposed fire
houses in the West Village and then
wonder why they're out of touches to
anyone who could be voting down will
trouble watch those shows and none of
them said 150 MIT someone good thing I
don't expect much from you CNN or ABC
NBC CBS MSNBC anyway I just just how it
every now and then every now and there's
a little huh
that's all I just want huh once not even
us not even a syllable really
just a guttural even you know what I'm
in hmm would suffice hmm that's it you
don't have to repeat what he said to
force him to question whether he's right
or wrong you know if someone just maybe
said with Joe Biden in his meetings 150
million if someone said that to me in
our pitch meetings yeah I would say a
hundred a million dead if someone said
150 million oh boy is that wrong you're
off by a hundred and forty nine point
five million a quarter black I would
have embarrassed myself on national
television all the internet but let's be
honest more people are watching this it
didn't even trend for the first hour
nobody cares anymore just break off some
pool cues let's go to the first example
and this is one to me that is not only
what he says but I think we have the
clip extender it so you can hear it kind
of feather out toward the end which is
the quote the soundbite is funny right
makes no sense but then he almost seems
as though he'd be like drank a bucket of
saltwater and that's what makes me think
he actually has some kind of
neurodegenerative disease damage I don't
know I would like to know the story this
where you talk about he talks about his
campaign running for let him fill in
blank I'm here to ask you for your help
where I come from you don't get far
unless you ask my name is Joe Biden I'm
a Democratic candidate for the United
States Senate look me over if you're
like me help out if not both the other
by give me a look though okay salvia
that Miley Cyrus no people were doing
back oh yeah does that make no sense 445
I don't know what happened first off you
might have forgotten that he said he's
running for Senate
fat check incorrect yeah that's wrong by
the way I'm giving you now I'm giving
you 19 for nokia's in that job I know to
help you you're running for some might
argue a more important office in the
land than Senate but their day and then
go inject a check me out
I just it is remarkable to me and here's
what I will say I know it's kind of fun
right now to watch the sort of civil war
in the crossfire and step back with the
with with the Democrats and I want you
to tell me who you think is most likely
to get the nomination Bernie's the
front-runner obviously but I also
think that is cruel I think that it's
cruel for Democrats of people
surrounding Vice President Joe Biden
right now to not bring to his attention
that there might be something seriously
wrong with them I'm not a medical
professional
this is not me spreading some kind of a
conspiracy theory okay I'm not saying
that I can confirm this but if I have
right now you know my family is held
above a piranha dunk tank and certain
death will await them if I have to place
this bet gun to my head again not a
qualified medical professional but I'm
pretty sure good Biden has dementia Hey
look my shirt just changed colors how
did that happen well it's the same way
that I can make the magic of the walrus
it's the magic of TV we can cut it and
then you're not watching this life but
hey there are videos playing in boxes
you can click one of those if you want
to watch more subscribe hit the
notification bell for all notifications
new videos every day 8:00 Eastern 9:00
Eastern I don't know it's one of those
and I hit like comment you don't have to
wait where did the cup go